if you're tired of your bank ripping you
off click the link below to learn about
our sponsor current which is an awesome
alternative to dealing with big banks
I'll tell you more about them at the end
of the video so let's now talk about the
embrace of let'em die by the Republican
Party lieutenant governor Dan Patrick of
Texas a Republican of course he's
scaling up his war on common sense and
his war on responsibility he now says
hey listen
with this coronavirus thing and you know
opening the country there are more
important things than living - which I
would say for who here he is on Tucker
Carlson's program last night I believe
it was but let's face reality of where
we are in Texas we have 29 million
people we've lost 495 that every life is
valuable but 500 people out of 29
million and we're locked down and we're
crushing the the average worker we're
crushing small business we're crushing
the markets we're crushing this country
and what I said when I was with you that
night there are more important things
than living and that's saving this
country for my children and my
grandchildren and saving this country
for all of us and I don't want to die
nobody wants to die but man we got to we
got to take some risk and get back in
the game and get this country back up
and running so as he refers to there he
did previously say he'd be willing to
sacrifice himself for the economy and
like I said before that's fine if he
wants to sacrifice himself but it's not
up to him to sacrifice other people for
what he sees as saving the economy
usually when they say save the economy
they really just mean the stock market
and it's similar here when Dan Patrick
says there are more important things
than living what he really means is
there are more important things to him
than other people living what is more
important than living two individuals
now there's another level of irony that
I would be remiss if I didn't mention
today about Dan Patrick we can't ignore
Dan Patrick's position on abortion if we
are going to seriously analyze what he
is saying about coronavirus dan Patrick
says in the context of opening barber
shops there are more important things
than living we've got to get the barber
shop open living is less important but
when it comes to a bore
dan Patrick believes ending a pregnancy
at eight weeks when you're talking about
a clump of cells that's murder he
campaigned on ending abortion and then
he flippantly says you know if a few
tens of thousands of grandparents have
to die
maybe even hundreds of thousands for the
stock market there are more important
things than living but if a clump of
cells at eight weeks exists it must be
protected as if it were the Secret
Service protecting the life of a
president the guy's a hypocrite he
doesn't appear to be a particularly good
person either and once again with the
religious right there's nothing more
important than people until they are
born at which point it's okay
to go without health insurance it's okay
to go without food it's okay to go
without education because we've got to
prop up the profits of all of these
industries they don't care if you have
to die to save the Dow from dropping
three extra points but if you want to
have an abortion they decide not the
women and the people that would be part
of those individual decisions between
patients and doctors this is what's so
difficult about fighting this they have
the wrong moral code they're wrong on
the facts and they don't care it's very
difficult to fight against people who
share those characteristics how do you
fight someone whose entire frame of
reference and factual basis is not only
incoherent it's wrong and it indicates
that they are not empathetic people it's
very very difficult the only real way to
fight them is overwhelm them with votes
at the ballot box in November as we've
been speaking about yesterday and today
during the interview segment with Rachel
bitter Kaufer convincing people to
change their mind is not an effective
way to win elections it's particularly
ineffective when their moral code seems
to be fundamentally malfunctioning to
them it seems to work but to us it seems
to be fundamentally malfunctioning we've
got to just find people and get them to
vote because these people are not going
to come around somebody who hears Dan
Patrick say listen barbershops are more
important than grandma living
but don't you dare even think about
getting yourself an abortion there's no
arguing with those people there just
isn't we've got to overwhelm them at the
ballot box
it's no secret on the show that I am
very critical of the big banks and how
they screw over customers in so many
ways and if you're like me you're
probably sick of the fees and the
hassles that come with a checking
account at a big traditional bank by now
in that case check out the online bank
current they're one of our sponsors if
you're watching on YouTube this here is
my actual debit card for my current
checking account which I'm holding up
with current you've got no minimum
balance no overdraft fees up to $100 no
ATM fees you can use over fifty five
thousand ATMs nationwide unlike with
other banks you receive your direct
deposit instantly meaning you'll get
paid by your employer up to two days
sooner you can deposit checks instantly
using your camera phone 24/7 member
support and unlike with other banks
current instantly refunds that hold on
your card when you pump gas you can
pause your debit card instantly which is
really useful there are just so many
different advantages to ditching the big
banks and instead use a bank that puts
their members first it takes two minutes
to sign up they'll immediately ship you
your debit card for free go ahead and
get started by clicking the link down
below the video